[Music]
a serial killer a vampire hunter and a
friend of mr bean the cast of the rings
of power have a fascinating history on
tv and film
one of the first characters cast for the
lord of the rings the rings of power was
tarmerial with american actor cynthia
die robinson landing the role the
rightful heir to the throne of numenor
and tolkien's work she's mentioned in
both unfinished tales and the similar
alien following the death of her father
tarmiriel should have become the leader
of the numenoreans but she was usurped
by her far zone when he forcefully
married her and took the throne for
himself the character in the television
show appears to be slightly different
from tolkien's version as she has been
described as queen regent of numenor
adai robinson is a pretty well known
television star having appeared in
several high profile shows over the
years she played navia in the historical
drama series spartacus and dc fans will
no doubt recognize her as amanda waller
from the cw's arrow the actor had a
recurring role in chicago med playing dr
vicky glass and she also appeared as
nadine in memphis in shooter she's also
been nominated for two women's image
network awards for her performance in
the history channel mini-series texas
rising
elrond is one of the characters in the
lord of the rings the rings of power who
was also present in peter jackson's film
trilogy the character portrayed by
british actor robert aramaio plays a
central part in the second age of
middle-earth during which he helped lead
the last alliance of elves and men
against sauron in battle with ellen dill
and gilgalad the amazon show deals with
elrond's traumatic past during a time
when he was much younger long before he
founded rivendell aramaio studied at new
york's juilliard school before he was
cast in harley in the davidsons in 2016
playing the titular bill harley for
three parts of the television miniseries
that same year rmio was cast as the
young eddard stark in game of thrones he
was seen fighting the king's guard at
the tower of joy to free his sister in a
flashback during season six he also
played elmer wayne henley jr and mind
hunter on netflix
although he only appears very briefly in
the lord of the rings films during
flashbacks the seal door is arguably one
of the most important characters in the
history of middle earth during the final
battle with sauron at the end of the
second age the seal door defeated the
dark lord but decided against destroying
the one ring maxim baldry plays this
vital character in the amazon show the
actor has revealed that a seal door will
be a vulnerable character in the first
season due to the loss of his mother and
his fraught relationship with his father
baldry remains relatively unknown in the
acting world though he's been around for
quite some time his first on-screen
roles were in 2007 when he landed parts
in the epic tv series rome and the
comedy film mr bean's holiday in 2016
baldry became a series regular on the
soap opera hollyoaks playing liam
donovan he's also had recent roles in
the likes of years and years doctor who
and last christmas
bronwyn is an entirely new creation for
the show played by nazanin bonyadi this
human character seemingly hails from the
southern lands of middle earth these
areas are not well described in any of
tolkien's writing and so any action
there is likely to feature brand new
individuals who are not part of the
canon of the literary works bonani has
been a regular fixture on television
screens for many years after making her
debut in the film game face in 2007 she
popped up as a reporter an iron man and
landed a regular role in general
hospital for over 100 episodes by 2011
the actor had become a recurring
character on how i met your mother in
which she played nora in tolkien's
fantasy world galadriel is possibly the
most powerful of all elves by the time
the lord of the rings takes place while
the character is much younger in the
rings of power she's still a formidable
force the younger galadriel plays a more
physical role in the fight against evil
wearing armor as opposed to the flowing
white robes she's known for you have not
seen what i've seen according to clark
herself she fainted shortly after she
found out she'd been cast as a famous
character clark has had a varied acting
career despite being a relative newcomer
her first credits came in 2014 when she
had roles in the television mini-series
new worlds in the movie the falling she
appeared in pride and prejudice in
zombies in 2016 and later had a
recurring role in his dark materials
playing sister clara in four episodes
more recently she applied her trade in
the bbc's dracula a mini-series from the
minds of sherlock co-creators mark
gaidis and stephen moffat
although he doesn't appear much in the
novels kelebrembor is still an important
figure in the lord of the rings played
by charles edwards in amazon's
adaptation he is an elephant a
descendant of feyenoor a master elven
craftsman who created the silmarils he's
known for forging the three rings of
power in the second elf stone
kelebrimbor's close alliance with the
dwarves of kaza doom and his
relationship with elrond are likely to
be vital to the rings of power going
forward edwards will be recognizable to
anyone who has watched downton abbey he
played the editor of the london magazine
the sketch and had a romantic
relationship with lady edith crawley
throughout the fourth season of the show
before that he betrayed michael palin in
the television movie holy flying circus
and sir arthur conan doyle and murder
rooms mysteries of the real sherlock
holmes
the husband of tarmerial and the last
king of numenor are far zoned as a
legendary figure in the mythology of the
lord of the rings following advice from
the dark lord arfaro zone set sail to
attack balinor resulting in eru who is
essentially god in tolkien's world
sinking his massive fleet and plunging
numenor into the sea tristan gravel
plays a character in the amazon series
over the years gravel has become a
familiar face in the united kingdom his
earliest role was in the television
series chosen but his big breakthrough
came in 2013 when he was cast as victor
colliano in mr selfridge he played that
role for some 34 episodes before taking
a part in e4 mini-series the aliens more
recently he has appeared in television
shows such as the terror baptist exile
and the discovery of witches
arandir is a character from the rings of
power that fans of the original books
will be unfamiliar with that's because
he's a brand new creation for the show
rather than someone who appears in
tolkien's work a silvan elf he travels
to the southern lands and eventually
comes to the village of tirgarod where
he meets and falls in love with bronwyn
it's a forbidden love but one that both
he and bronwyn are willing to fight for
a native of puerto rico ismail cruz
cordova first came to the public's
attention when he portrayed mondo on
sesame street in 2016 he betrayed hector
compost and the television series ray
donovan and then he had a role in the
2017 show the catch as the hammer the
following year he was cast as rafael
torres in the drama series berlin
station fans of the star wars franchise
may recognize him from the mandalorian
in which he portrayed the twilight
mercenary quinn
sonic burroughs played by lenny henry is
another new character introduced in the
world of the lord of the rings in the
amazon series a harfoot one of the three
types of hobbits in middle earth
burroughs is part of a nomadic tribe
that moves around avoiding contact with
men to steer clear of any conflict the
skies
are strange
starting his career as a stand-up
comedian henry was one of the most
influential black comics in britain
during the 1980s he was so successful
that he was given his own series in the
form of the lenny henry show in 1984
making his shakespeare debut in 2009 he
was praised by critics for his
performance as othello henry is also
well known for being one of the
co-founders of comic relief a charity
that has raised millions for good causes
elendil is a pivotal figure in the
history of middle earth as one of the
few survivors of the downfall of numenor
leading the rest of the living
numenoreans to middle earth he founded
the kingdoms of arnor and gondor and as
the direct ancestor of aragorn as high
king of the dunadine elendell was an
enemy of sauron and led the forces of
men against him in the war of last
alliance with gilgalad and his elves
he's portrayed by lloyd owen in the
amazon show a veteran of television and
film owen's first major role came in the
young indiana jones chronicles where he
played a younger professor henry jones
senior following this he played adam in
the comedy series get real throughout
1998 and had roles in several british
shows such as casualty and wire in the
blood he's probably best known for his
parts as paul bowman and monarch of the
glenn
eleanor brandy foot better known by her
nickname nori is a hard foot played by
australian actor markela cavanaugh a new
character who doesn't appear in the book
she is featured briefly in teaser
trailers for the rings of power
inspecting a meteorite landing in an
area inhabited by harfoots one of the
youngest members of the cast kavanaugh
had only a handful of credits to her
name when she joined the amazon show she
played cindy and romper stomper in 2018
and she followed that up with recurring
appearances in picnic at hanging rock
and cry she portrayed daisy heart in the
australian supernatural thriller the
gloaming and she has had film roles in
true history of the kelly gang my first
summer and furlough
ariane is another non-canonical
character in terms of tolkien's works
played by emma horvath she's a
numenorean and will play a prominent
role as the daughter of elendil in an
interview with entertainment weekly
horvath described her as a determined
woman who is still quite insecure and
naive about the way the world works her
name can be translated to daughter of
the sea from the elvish language quenya
her first role came in like share follow
in 2017 followed by parts in the gallows
act 2 and the mortuary collection she is
perhaps best known for her role in the
television series don't look deeper
where she portrayed jenny for 11
episodes more recently she starred in
the 2020 horror film what lies below
award-winning actor peter mullen plays
during the third in the rings of power
although it's never established that
he's the father of duran iv in tolkien's
writings that is the case in the show
which caused some controversy among
readers a king of durian's folk he was
given one of the seven dwarf rings and
possessed the greatest of them his ring
was provided directly by kelebrimbor
rather than sauron and it would remain
with his family for thousands of years
beyond the darkness tempting shadow to
bury us all beneath the mountain as one
of the oldest members of the cast mullen
also has one of the longest careers in
acting beginning in the late 80s the
scottish actor appeared in films like
riff raff and shallow grave before
landing parts in trainspotting and
braveheart he's perhaps best known for
his turn in 1998's my name is joe
winning the award for best actor at the
cannes film festival that year recently
he's appeared as james delos and hbo's
westworld
as played by benjamin walker in the
rings of power gilgalad is an elven king
known as the lord of uriador and the
high king of the elves of the west he is
a hugely important figure and an
influential character in the world of
middle earth in tolkien's works he plays
a significant part in defeating sauron
as one of the leaders of the last
alliance of elves and men his first role
came in the liam neeson film kinsey
where he portrayed a teenage version of
the title character the actor then went
on to have roles in movies such as
abraham lincoln vampire hunter and in
heart of the sea however he is probably
most recognizable for his role in
netflix's marvel series jessica jones as
a character eric in 2022 he portrayed
captain eve and the king's daughter
[Music]